Hi! I'm Jen Aniston and I'm here to talk to you about smartwater.
But in this day and age apparently, I can't just do that, can I?
Can't just tell you that smartwater is the smartest, best tasting water that's out there.
I have to make a video apparently, that turns into a virus.
Viral.
So,...
We need the video to go viral.
Right.
Sorry, viral.
Thank you.
This is why I have these three lovely Internet boys here to help me.
So apparently, well, animals are huge online.
Do we have animals?
Oh, you're so sweet.
Can you say, "I love smartwater"?
No, no, no! Out of there.
I love smartwater.
Rachel, I love your hair.
Okay, that's enough.
Let's try to think of something else.
Okay well, that's adorable.
Look at you, guys.
Look at them!
Wait, what are you doing?
No, no, no. No dirty dancing, babies.
It'll get us more views.
It'll also get us arrested!
Babies, stop that.
You really can't do that, yet.
Where's the mommy?
Full-on, double rainbow all the way across the sky!
What's going on?
Oh my God!
Hi! Honey, are you okay?
It's so beautiful.
What? Come on, let's get you up.
Here, have some smartwater.
What did they do to you?
Anything else? What's left?
Oh my God, Jen Aniston.
I've been in love with you forever.
Sorry. Apparently, that's worth about 100,000 hits.
Not for me.
God! Is it hot in here?
I'm fired.
Well in closing, I would like to say that smartwater is the purest tasting water there is.
What are we gonna call this video?
Jen Aniston's sex tape?
I love it.